Hair Spray I don't know how much
Derrick's willing to make that we're
gonna be able to sell it wholesale
that nut butter dude imagine dark nut
butter
jongup butter whole enjoy it's not
chocolate it's the same as ours but I'm
just saying it comes out of more of like
a you know I would say more of a
Brazilian nut I would assume that's what
Derrick probably has just think of an
Ice King the sting nut butter now take
what you want with that do you think it
feels the same if you're a black guy
that Jack you lates or an asian guy or
if you're like a Japanese guy all right
different for everyone you know I know
it could be different for everyone yeah
I know that God but I'm saying do you
think it's different feeling for
different ethnicities oh yeah you do
oh yeah white guys bust the hardest yeah
well first of all you don't know you
only know how you boss dude okay you
only know how you bust and how you're
the girl you have kidnapped in your
basement if you're gonna just keep
somebody sment accepting sex all the
time you should move to Cleveland bro
because that seems to be a popular area
for that they allow it out there shout
out Indians dude but no I'm just saying
really burnin why don't you think about
stuff more often yeah you might be right
dude my drum busting nuts not even
thinking about how other probably feel
when they do it yeah you're right man
you're right I don't I didn't consider
it really nope not once
wow dude sometimes I'll dress up in
different outfits or something but I'm
gonna ejaculate and put a wig on I won't
do a wig really yeah all right but it
gives a wig guy it cuts off my
circulation I can't think it's hard if I
have a tight wig on my head but I will
do different outfits or something to
make me feel like more regional or you
know like I'm from a certain area or
you're put a mask on mMmmm nope
mmm-hmm I never done a match just like a
Hawaiian tropical shirt if you're in
Maui oh I've done
no not for I don't dress for where I am
I dressed for who I imagined to be okay
so I'll dress you know I'll put on like
a lot of different you know I might have
like if I'm gonna imagine that I'm
somebody you know that's maybe from Guam
or something since Guam can you look
that up also I like to put on a
sleeveless vest I think I'm in the 80s
action movie like commando and jacket
hard with leather gloves
dude spitballing ideas here I thought
you're right actually that's a good
that's a pretty good idea so what I'm
saying though is that you but you sound
more like a chauffeur like you're like
basically just a chauffeur for your own
wiener dude what I'm talking about is
someone who I'm talking about having a
ethnic experience Brendan I'm not
talking about occupational you're
dressing up like would you say again
would you put on like a command of the
bad guy in command I always had
sleeveless shirts on it was really I
think it was more of a fishnet
chain-link sleeveless shirt and he had
gloves on like big Jay oakerson big Jay
oakerson is a whale I think that got
busted in one of those videos did you
see that down in black that's who I
picture myself as what a jacket okay so
gangster well if you stop it the first
part of that word that dude is well if
you separate the two words into one
thing that dude is a gangster bro that
dude will show up with six guns set them
all on the side of your bed and bang the
[ __ ] out of your mother if you're a nude
man because that man and make sure don't
and I want I want us to put indecent
pictures of this guy don't a lot of
times we put in a picture doesn't even
reference to God correctly if you see
this man this dude is yes yeah yeah
that's right
is his name Bennet I believe it's Bennet
yeah this guy works for the Boys & Girls
Club of America but often asked them if
they could just leave the girls
let's just say that he gave all of all
he could handle Bennett was his name
like my Vernon Wells he'll well Vernon
Wells dude who invented um I think you
were at like 10,000 Leagues Under the
Sea or something yeah I like to picture
myself as him knows the point man well
that guy's a white guy though with a
moustache so I mean it's babies a bad
guy 80s huh he's a bad guy in the
eighties okay so you're saying you're
you are willing to have a back to the
future sexual sensual kind of a 3d
virtual experience of your own in
commando but you go into more like a bad
guy or an into a bank and now yep
can I am I allowed to ejaculate yeah and
if it's real special thing of Wesley
Snipes and demolition man you have the
dude I thought we're spit ball and I'd
are we live I've been alive for a long
time bro I thought we spit ball an idea
or a figurine bro you are pretty much
probably your parents are Mattel it is a
strawberry summer my man
if strawberry summer wow we had a great
conversation you want Brendan bailed it
out cuz he seizes something on a shirt
yeah dude strawberries all over your
shirt yeah there's a really nice shirt
Brendan it is that you look nice man and
I'll say actually this is from a company
called breakfast shirts in Australia and
they make shirts that are just to be
worn at breakfast and this is actually
my breakfast this coffee I haven't had
anything yet so you can only wear them
yeah you can't really wear that for
dinner didn't got this jersey Celtics 23
all right huh I don't know where you get
your clothes dude the Celtics [ __ ]
Jersey dude that's no Boston Celtic
Jersey I've never seen you don't think
so let me see the back look at this
business she said Oh interesting
no it's a very confusing Jersey
Covington Lousiana City chance bro is
that an official Boston Celtics Jersey
I don't know how official it is I mean I
think they would recognize it if you
brought it up - I don't think so cuz
just the T works on that shirt dude
first of all I won the city championship
in Covington Lousiana in this shirt
right here score when I was 12 years old
probably about fourteen points of it
good
Salgado rebounds seven travels dude I
would travel all the time [ __ ] you know
I'm saying dude but also let it go
hey rest let him go let us play ball bro
dude head us ball after the third travel
bro you know what I'm saying you look
how you'd be the kid that come in and
just foul the other kids real no dude I
was really put me in for defense a lot
of times they put me in yeah a lot of
times they would tell me no offense
sometimes sometimes they would even make
me stay at one end of the court while
the other four guys went to play off it
that's fair
how did kids score at 80 points on me
name was Jason Williams he went on he
scored 80 points he scored 40 on my best
friend and then went but coach went we
got switched up siya begin my I'll take
it from here and then he just busted my
ass like 40 I took 40 best friend took
40 that's pretty cool these white guys
coming one black guy yeah Jason Williams
is white litany wrong Jason Williams
it's a black text this is a black Jason
I don't know what to do there's a jitter
so there's a multiple so there's a let's
let's untangle this Jason Williams thing
there's Jason Williams played for like
shatter that boy you thinking white
chocolate what who played for the
Sacramento Kings and his sons a super
little white chocolate is he really yeah
like an N one kind of white chocolate
but then Jason Williams played for Duke
drove a motorcycle screwed up his knee
now he's an analyst for ESPN and then
Jason Williams who busted my ass for 80
points from prairie middle school on
Colorado so nobody even [ __ ] knows is
due to beat you
ah I don't know what he's doing now but
he was a stellar middle school player
this is middle school you know feels
like another kid bust 80 points on your
ass in middle school I have to go back
to school the next day bro it's middle
school where the field judge of the
Royal Hills Mustangs
[Music]
stank stay so some dude with middle
schools when they have wooden
backboards but remember that shoot back
boy [ __ ] wood and sometimes the thing
like the thing where they drew like the
square some would be a rectangle yeah
and there'd be chained [ __ ] but net the
net was chained yeah Jesus bro so
something we don't even know beat you at
least give be by a decent person who
knows what he went on to do 80 points in
some brand new J's well Jordan fors
still terrorized me to this day really
rich fors Romney man I flashbacks
wow man
another sport you couldn't handle bra on
was not for me sir isn't shut out to
this somebody sent us this huh that's
pretty cool pop some bottles this king
in the sting it doesn't have to be out
ball cuz I know you don't drink alcohol
you get pop Mexican coca-cola with that
maybe we should bring home to my family
yeah should how about these passes in my
household brought Mexican sprite you
ever heard of that way yes free sprit
day yes freak day boy that's the spirit
day give me that give me that
Cola give me this Breda oh I want the
coca-cola but the white one yeah it all
tastes like the Spree it all tastes
exactly the same it all tastes exactly
the same Oh Cola Blanco they kept sayin
Pastor Mike Cinco corn went past the
white Cola bro yeah white Cola well shut
off City champs dude we won this bro
wanted in this Jersey bro 27 years ago I
won that [ __ ] gang [ __ ] that's when we
use them to paint in this but we have to
go work for our coach before the games
in paint I like just get out there
little work ethic cardio up I like how
it still fits exactly the same so we had
a guy on our team had to be 31 years old
too
there's always one of those yeah this
guy big Clarence day did you ever did
you have kids in middle school that
could dunk yeah God is we had one kid
named Kirby bruh and they used to call
him quiet was his name cuz he never said
anything wrong he wasn't deaf but he was
just kind of verbally lazy you know yeah
and dude nobody thought he could do
anything read or do anything and then
one day he [ __ ] punked bro from no
joke brush he dumped from like probably
almost a three point line
like yeah bro it was so amazing he
started crying after if he were crying
cuz he knows the pussy's gonna [ __ ]
see that no no a basketball in middle
school no I wasn't making about [ __ ]
Brendan it was that he finally done
something positive or he done something
he felt good about or he's gonna get the
[ __ ] out of what a shitty neighborhood
he grew up why cuz I mean didn't MBA
come I don't know he didn't get any make
me a contracts dude he never even joined
that in one circuit is his name
earthquake bring up earthquake for me
because this is who I think you're
referring to I [ __ ] knew it dude
Herbie grew up with earthquakes boy
named Kirby Martin bro Kirby Pucket
shout-out Kirby Martin brothers dude and
he had nobody and one basketball Kirby
Pucket can you dig it his name also
might been Escalade you know what his
name is Escalade oh yeah true be
turned-in Escalade we're the last thing
you need is another vehicle dude alright
yeah you ain't lyin bro Jesus Chris is
yeah there is that Kirby does that look
like him going down where he's like
trying to do it yeah there's Kirby
[ __ ] yeah that man's dead now I think uh
that boy could who could either or could
he just take pictures when he was in a
jersey dude watch your mouth around
escalator oh he could drive what's he
gonna do dude [ __ ] double Park near
the hoop this guy this guy [ __ ]
couldn't parallel park a three-pointer
if you gave him if you give him two
hours worth of quarters there and a
meter remember there was like there was
white chocolate there was hot sauce
Escalade half man half amazing uh yeah
Miriam did you watching that n1 stuff
man and one was it was dragon boy
remember that guy he was from a
neighboring town buy us bro and I swear
to god dude he would lay up on the road
when it was hot after it rain but the
Sun had his stomach yeah like a lizard
yeah hell yeah and it go on the dragon
boy the dragon he could double dribble
bruh yeah point is those rafts in middle
schools let the kids play man
yeah what do you mean what riffs rather
than arrest it's you and a couple of
other [ __ ] thick boys [ __ ] milling
around after school dude no no you tell
about that streetball no I'm talking
about you guys and [ __ ] whatever it
was priority Catholic [ __ ] middle
school or wherever you go Hills bro yeah
roars Hillsboro sounds nice dude
okay not nice I went to no windows bro I
went to no windows no Hill no Hills
middle school no Hills okay the young
Gunners dude and actually you know who
went to our middle school and I talked
about this in my comedy special a while
back but um Lee Harvey Oswald bro lho
gang [ __ ] city chairs our [ __ ] team
for about 16 years and yeah damage
museum Lee Harvey Oswald they might have
it bro believe he actually shot the
president you believe in the conspiracy
theory with that look I went there I
kind of spaced it out myself I kind of
paste it out I did a little bit of you
know I wouldn't say investigation but I
did use a tape measure while I was there
um did you go to the window in the
library I went up there I went from the
window to the wall dog
[Laughter]
I'm in Dallas this weekend you get your
LC I'm gonna do it again
Lee Harvey Oswald man la chaise some
people call him a [ __ ] traitor I think
it was a goddamn hero whoa
do you even black people here I'm with
you on this let's go to Derrick for how
you guys feel JFK for life go over oh I
love JFK but there's a conspiracy theory
that on Lee Harvey Oswald if you look
into it if you look into it if you look
into it he didn't do it himself man
there's some shady business going on mom
tell me I a bro get see I'm triply up in
this [ __ ] spit some [ __ ] knowledge
and guys there oh I agree same as a lot
of interesting things happening inside
of his brain and look I'm not saying
he's wrong brinel trust any of these
cats dude I don't know who did it but I
think you need to go there and do some
of the work man I went to the place
where he stayed I don't want to the
Breck the Ville I went to the room you
can go to the room I went there to bring
you really yeah the house where he
stayed and we rented a little room there
yeah you went there oh yeah [ __ ] yeah
dude I hit something on the bed there
yeah me too I it's my name under the
[ __ ] headrest the board said be
Shabbos here gang gang shot shot Jesus
man
yeah that's interesting though man shut
up the Dallas a shout-out to JFK but
that's that's too much dude I can't
believe you went to your school it makes
a lot of light so bro gang [ __ ] man
hey dude yeah a lot of little rumors
around town about him but but yeah man
these are awesome this thing came from
native so we just want to shout out this
company I didn't even know that they
sent us this but either we should get
one of these we're gonna come up with a
new merch shop and we should get some of
these anything yeah we should they're
dope huh they do Pat them bollocks weeks
used it a bunch and how do you guys feel
let's get a Vietnamese piece on uh JFK
what do you guys think about him cat
honestly I've never given him much
thought until this moment welcome to uh
America he's something we think about
he's someone you're growing up you think
about him from time to time would you
agree with that there absolutely he said
a lot you've it the most stylish
president we've ever had
bust a ton of nuts on the road okay
Marilyn Monroe he's the best president
we've ever had him and Marilyn Monroe
used to date actually they have a place
that no joke is probably about nine
blocks from here right on Ocean Park
right uh right on Ocean Park where Ocean
Park and Pacific right there meet and
they had a bar that they used to go to
all the time that's pretty cool pretty
cool JFK Marilyn Monroe with them
dangerous curves like the original can
you guys think about Marilyn Monroe does
she have any a cat in your world is she
she just a thought what was she to me
she just a thought that's [ __ ]
waiting for some sunburn that's all I
really think they made it
in our culture we kind of see her as a
Geisha she's like the American geisha
you know very pretty does sexual things
for people high in power a lot of girls
love to use her quotes as like as
they're like yeah inspiration myspace
captioned Instagram captions mm-hmm dude
she would suck her way to the top and
good for her yeah I got a lot of big
roles for it she was a she's the first
kind of one with curves that's true boys
disrespecting her I'm just saying it up
chicks bringing all the books of the
yard damn right damn dude but Marilyn
Monroe is the first one to do it I just
want to be Weinstein just took it over
the top but there's a lot of people out
there like this yeah Harvey Weiner steam
brother [ __ ] or Weiner steer that
diddle steers Weiner right at you yeah
I've been put you in Batman - so sign me
the [ __ ] up
well here's the thing though a lot of
ugly dudes were complaining about this
[ __ ] it's all ugly dudes getting busted
you know it's real ugly dudes with power
and then real hideous women also
complaining you don't see no fine chick
complaining you don't see the new
superhero chicken wing oh this is
ridiculous
she's like [ __ ] I get my hand job now
I'm [ __ ] marvel
I don't know about that far but I do
know one lady I think here owes him a
gallon or something lady from Titanic or
whatever yeah she got busted she's in
the craft right I don't know dude but
she [ __ ] knew stuff but she banged
once she [ __ ] one of my dudes in a
hotel room and over their office yeah
this lady Rose on
now she grows hold up see original thug
gross now she used to be Hollywood's
little black girl this is she used to be
bad really up the black magic tits go to
her when she would dude when she was
with Marilyn Manson she was on that good
good dude before she got all crazy over
dicks
she was dope yeah this is drug rose I
think they call her now because she
might be on drugs because she's a bummer
rose yeah cuz she looks a little bit
like dog Rose if you look at her yeah
body's a little different but when she
shaved her head she definitely I see
what you're saying there what do you
mean you see what I'm saying can we get
a picture of thug rose and drugged rose
up here Friday you see what I'm saying
is they both have shaved heads you think
Oh lips what same very similar no you're
right all right I'll give you that Doug
I'll give you that I'd take the girls
over drugged Rose any day dude right
yeah what you're saying his drug run in
1998 she banged a couple dudes on though
of a tear-off for the arm at that hotel
over there off Sunset she banged all the
dudes and started complaining yeah and
then she complain people's [ __ ]
people yeah use one of the people use
the main people yeah the one that
started this riot yeah she why don't
know I mean she definitely was [ __ ]
people for no reason which is what most
people are doing yeah it's called a good
time yeah I think she was just upset
about maybe some of her work curry or
something but I would watch them fight
bro put all my money on thug rows over
drug rows yeah all day done well let's
get into this [ __ ] I don't know where at
shut up - well I was just trying to be
accepted of other cultures by saying
sometimes I'll try and have an
experience and I was trying to relate to
you know I said yeah me too sometimes
like to think I'm back in the 80s and
Jack off the bad guys in 80 movies very
similar maybe it's not very and then you
brought up how much
in love with Harley Harvey Lee Oswald
okay
that's that would be a cello and that's
not him
Harvey Lee Oswald is no one that's
nobody at least respect the man and
respect his work bro change the history
didn't he I don't know what he did bro
but I'll tell you this man if you go to
the window where it happened in there
you gotta be you better be doing three
months of yoga and be really good with a
gun to be able to pull these shots
you better be Bradley Cooper an American
sniper yeah and especially the old gun
he used come on bro you ain't I ain't
buying none of that [ __ ] yeah he had a
gun I think he had to put gasoline in
the bottom of it like a musket do this
and then this ain't small miss small
dude I don't think Mel Gibson could have
[ __ ] hit that shot dude but who knows
man I'm not buying it downfield see this
weekend Alice
oh damn bro those people from your show
into Alice let's get into something
entertaining Derrick please I'm tired
there's racism by [ __ ] Brendan over
here go I start talking about sexual
experiences culturally and he goes back
to him and some other [ __ ] chub boy
you didn't [ __ ] blast it on for 40
points by some dude that works at a
[ __ ] Jiffy Lube get your life Jamba
Juice you [ __ ]
time to pay the bills bro maybe you need
strawberries at midnight with that shirt
maybe we need some honeycombs in the
middle of the afternoon there may be
damn maybe need a gun ah maybe need a
gun show there are guns but these are
fast knives boy Oh what's up dawg you me
get post mates your personal food
delivery grocery delivery whatever kind
of delivery service you need 24/7 365
days a year
yeah post mates is a definite really
really a great thing if you thinking
about you know you don't know who you
are dude you want somebody to come to
your house and tell you who you are by
giving you a type of food or something
post mates if you can get candy canes
and solve all your problems
post mates yeah dude say you can't even
walk
or your grandfather can't walk get him
that candy cane bro you know what I'm
saying change his [ __ ] sugar game up
dude
post mates but I'll have somebody you
don't even do you want to meet somebody
you don't have any friends brought by a
taco some humans [ __ ] shows up with a
dog there's your new hero right there's
like this out maybe you got a crush get
her a dozen donuts nothing says I love
you like us fresh pair of 12 glazed yeah
if you really care about her burn down a
[ __ ] Dunkin Donuts a spray paint her
name on the [ __ ] cement outside dude
that shows some real bad boy mom
download the app on your Android or
iPhone right now browse local
restaurants and businesses and track
your delivery in real time hit him with
a deal mr. Thiele Vaughn real time this
ain't freakin leap year son we talking
about legit [ __ ] boy for a limited time
post mates is giving our listeners $100
of free delivery credit for your first
seven days filthy yup that's right to
start your free deliveries download the
app and use code Kay 80s to zero one
nine
that's code K 80s to zero one nine for
$100 a free delivery credit for your
first seven days when you download the
post mates app anything you need anytime
you want it post mated download post may
send save with code k 80s to zero one
nine alright love it support the podcast
here's an ad
shut up to your boy damn bro dude let me
see him
dude the honey badger hit mine bro what
you got dude ugh well yeah those are
cool touch me bro but keep touching and
session we got Stan's socks on we both
Rock and I'm Daniel Ricciardo limited
edition Stan's formula 1 socks son
the honey badger you dig in these what
you dig in these won't stance we'll do a
sock of ours why don't they do a sock a
collab with us stance you hate money you
hate selling socks
king of sing socks do this game game
smoke my gun sign what's up dawg what
I'm talking about is keeping people's
feet warm you look I got ominous stances
since I can't even remember
I was a kid dude since I was pre-k a
brother since I was a zygote dude if you
look on my ultrasound I got stances on
some dude listen stances hands down the
best suction get they paired up with the
NBA MLB Star Wars The Office Formula One
drivers like my boy Daniel Ricciardo
Andre 3000 Pistol Pete Maravich stance
has had all the hitters on how many of
you know someone who's obsessed with Sox
well you know what I'm talking about a
real sock jockey well it's time to get
them the Christmas gift of the year so
you want to try some stance sakis you
want try some stance on keep it up deal
all right man get a free pair of socks
with their next order that's right when
you already get a free pair all you have
to do is go to Stan's comm slash cats k
ATS that stance comm slash cats all
right it's the best gift it's the gift
that keeps on giving this holiday season
take the guesswork out of holiday
shopping Stan's makes the perfect gift
look fly keep your feet warm what else
you want what else you want get that
Stan's hero get those socks you can do
it Stan Tom slash cats
Tom got spayed for Theo's haircut first
we got a debate club this is [ __ ] RTD
didn't give us full minute RTD named
after that one that little yeah oh wow
this guy's in a wheelchair I'm sorry man
hello my question is for the debate club
section I want to know do you guys like
the [ __ ] you know New Age [ __ ]
flatters flat flat head the flat heads
you know yeah I got or the [ __ ] old
school throw it back on them let's have
their first game Chris Kyle gang shiteru
salute gang that's all JK what is that
that's a
for that Derek can you give us another
translate that would be safe out there
bro word from that's a crazy thing to
say out loud
what's he saying there dere can we buy
the N part again and you we translate
that for us brother
school throw it back on them Gang Gang
PI room
subbu gae-soo what does that say Derek
we're talking to Derek Brendan
affiliated gang and ensue you know it's
like they're uh it's their bird call
it's their like you know like that's
their uh and what if they doing hiking
or something like what do you mean or if
you needed to just you know get a member
let's say you needed to get a gang
member from across the streets attention
but you didn't want to say his name
hey y'all good game so a lot of text or
anything
I mean sometimes yeah but you never know
what service these days and then who
might be team are on her phones yeah
people changing the numbers yeah you
know could get wireless well thank you
for that translation of course paint God
your hair ah the flat bill the flat bill
is tough for me I got a wired head so
it's tough for me to pull off the flat
bill the whitest and and also white guy
in the flat bill it's okay it's not as
blank guy you can put anything on a
black guy's head they look good they
look cool especially when you black guys
when they tilt to the sides like beer
you're seeing jay-z it's like do I think
they'll fall off with a strong yeah blow
of a weird like this sad no matter what
he has on though he's never really been
a handsome guy that guys can pull those
hats off it's like just barely barely
yeah white guy you can't do black guy
you'll see a hat and then tied to a
string about 11 feet away tied to the
back of his head and it'll be still look
cool it looks really dope like why you
guys they really fold the bills
you goddamn em very organized yeah I'm
saying you got a because that's what its
purpose this for to block the goddamn
Sun in it yeah that's true
so black guys a lot of skin cancer a lot
of sugar issues he's a black guy with a
hat on and then like this the block the
Sun
and upset about all of it and I got this
thing sighs dude you gotta use the hat
people forgetting the use for the Hat
okay what do you see when you see
different man in these different hats
how does that come across to you I think
it depends some men I think look good in
hats but you have to be careful as a
woman if you're dating coz there's this
thing called hat fishing where he may
look really good when he wears a hat but
he takes it off and you realize he has a
[ __ ] up hairline
[Music]
hat fishing huh Oh like cat fishing hat
fishing we should do a show called
Kaposi where we go fishing with you cat
do you like to fish or not dude I have
never done to me didn't that be the best
[ __ ] show ever that best show ever
and we just can't know we go I think
it's called yodeling and we put our
hands in the catfish noodling yeah yeah
but noodling you put your hands balls
deep in the catfish and get them out of
the tunnel don't they bite you it's a
help not if you hit it right not if you
hit it right get it right get it done
yeah you in I am not in any I'm not even
in this conversation
that's how not in Iran that's fair it's
a very new or nothing it's an Oklahoma
type of thing where they do to catfish
no it's not dude they do the noodling uh
bra dude the recipes are so good in
Louisiana a lot of the fish show up too
just to get involved in the [ __ ] pot
saying cooked me bro yeah dog you'll see
a cook you'll see a fish with a tattoo
on his finish has grilled me up mf'er
yeah like damn he got that tat bro
deep-fry a baby gang [ __ ] yeah look at
these dude and this is another way to
meet and semi-nude men if you look at
some of these photos West Virginia
makes sense oh yeah look at that guy I
mean if this ain't the size of them
fresh one of these pictures on tinder
it's our rag
deal and it's hairy badly that dude is
bad forearm down a fricking carp bra
you know this get that dude it well
check out the [ __ ] get the time in
peace so look at the two men let's click
on the two men right there yeah
dude can we zoom in on that a picture or
get the picture laughter well that with
it they kind of whale that's a baby
whale that ain't cool there should not
be let ease the internet unbelievable we
still log in yeah it makes you log in
for pretentious [ __ ] haters well just
go to the picture to zoom on the screen
if you don't mind yeah there we go there
we go
oh look at that bro you telling me those
two people holding that big fish ain't
gonna [ __ ] meet each other later for
something you know they're gonna meet
later for at least a drink have to a lot
of men they'll go fish and you'll see
them later meeting for a drink after an
experience like that catching this
[ __ ] monster look at the tits on that
[ __ ] red fish yeah my god you'd film
us going noodling dude I know people are
listening we'll take your new link we do
need some advice on how to do it so you
don't do it right the catfish [ __ ] you
up well look man if we ever did a tour
it'd be great to go do some stuff out in
the world but I can only ask you so many
times to do tour dates though and I've
given you days this is like oh come on
now bro got the igloo I got a sign the
[ __ ] violent killer doesn't sleep
somebody bites on a pillow that guy
[ __ ] does not sleep do you could see
the bombs in his eyes bro every time I
start talking oh my he refused going in
the distance man shut up well that's not
in [ __ ] these days I'm saying it's safe
to go to Brendan shows but it's not as
safe as it used to be that's fair bro
it's kidding [ __ ] urban out there and
I'm talking sand urban you don't you
have 50 shades of sand baby
I'm talking about dude this guy's BYO
dunes this new is [ __ ] bring his sand
bro what are we talking about super gay
there's no [ __ ] way these dudes ain't
like a meeting each other
there's be some noodling all right man I
feel bad for the women at home that are
just pretending that they're living in
our and a real family in a hetero family
bro this is real catfishing wheres nev
at solving this case yeah where is Nev
Schulman dude that [ __ ] guy who takes
advantage of poor people don't know how
to use phones no let's look into this
and then also you got a show all he does
is google their name 22-minute show
around that [ __ ] and really I think
that's oh as a racial sometimes I feel
like that show makes fun of a biker but
don't know how to use fun it's just
black people it really is dude at a
certain point I feel like it is cuz he's
black people and then it's black people
still on MySpace getting catfished yeah
and it's always like and I really do I
think and I don't mean that in any like
racial what but I just think at this I
feel like it's it's not like
appropriation but it's just like [ __ ]
up Dawg like go get some [ __ ] other
people bruh you know I'm saying yeah I
agree
have you have you seen their new show
ghosted mm-hm it's people that went on
dates and then they ghost them cuz they
didn't like the person then they hunt
the person down bag why did you go so
he's like because I was that's a TV show
you tracked me down cuz I didn't like
the [ __ ] five that's a DVD ghosted
insane
get your life together smoke my nuts
brother oh yeah do more teen moms
Dyrdek's Network now it's all it is is
ridiculous yeah shut up to rob them yeah
Rob's our worker managers a legend but
Teen Mom what's next my ten year old on
there all right I had twins they had a
3000 with twins in them dude it's all
like southern poor white people through
that's the other thing they take
advantage of that demo yeah go get yeah
saying dude nah bro ya mix it up rich
kid in the hills you got pregnant yeah
find some other [ __ ] bro yeah
so I'm saying dude somebody shows it as
take advantage of poor people i watch
the [ __ ] out of it though
look I watch it I watch the dateline
really and anybody could get murdered no
matter what your price range is and
that's one thing I do respect about
murder dawn to sky's the limit gang [ __ ]
man this guy right let's move on i sayin
bro this guy's got a problem dude dude
here's the thing flat bills occured
bills when you're black it doesn't
matter if you're white it better be
curved I don't know if I see one four
five panel if you see a black on a curve
bill dude that's a unique man I feel
like yeah and he's in a Ford commercial
well that one lady whoever did that was
remember the guy with the eye patch in
that commercial yeah dude
very strange we went down a weird road
with that like I got hit by a rock
they've been hit by a rock member
everybody looks like they didn't want to
be there but that is an interesting man
when you see a black gentleman in a
curve bill what do you is that that's a
little unique I think coach a big black
guy in a curve ball i think either cuz
really I think Chappelle they see that
Nine Inch Nails yeah but it's don't know
the difference it's kind of the same
well a 58% of people went with curved on
this one
yeah flat bill yeah I have some real
swaggy style or be black or you got to
be younger I think it's also a younger
generation thing you know older
generation they won't you know you won't
see a lot of dads in the flat bill
unless he just left unless the wife just
left him or something he's trying to
figure it out there's nothing you know
anyone who's rocking pro backs lately
like a straight up pro back when I was a
kid Pro Beck's was the [ __ ] I never
heard of Pro back toe backs like the
real like what the MLB players wear it's
not like a snapback you know how there's
like adjustable I'm talking real pro
back like you get like a real Yankee sat
a real Dodgers had the pro back Doug
well you probably wear a nine and a half
in pro back I were eight and uh what am
i eating something I remember the day I
found out that they had fitted hats it
changed my whole world bro my bad dude
and when I got that bro yeah I got a
noggin bro you know I remember my mom
was dating this dude named Kevin forget
his last name realtor when the Colorado
Rockies is our first MLB team he was so
crunk
he hits hit the biggest head you've ever
seen in your life screwed my mom over
whatever but anyways we went to this
store to get the first Colorado Rockies
hat his head was so big been in have one
for him
his eyes swelled up with tears you wash
your must agree that [ __ ] I'll take it
off like nine give me that [ __ ] it's
like this Bobby
[ __ ] big wheels over here dumbass
[ __ ] Bremen AM dude I can't fit into
a [ __ ] snapback and that last one was
[ __ ] they're hanging on [ __ ] his
head was so big was like this
shut up the cabin ah yeah dude somebody
had to squeeze into a hat
they can't even open their eyes anymore
that hat so tight dude like Danny got
that tight hat boy boy yeah so what is
this guy's problem again what the [ __ ]
is God want to tell you it's noodling
got catfished or hot fish look you seem
blessed man you got to [ __ ] hats man
you got a head even though you
communicate kind of like that guy who
was in hoodoo who's the guy who talked
about space all the time he was in a
wheelchair Hawking yeah you can do
Hawkins if you go back and listen to
this duty as a very Stephen Hawking ass
type of communication pattern let's
listen to him from the beginning it's
very slow Stephen Hawkins real hello my
question is for the debate club is to
pay repulsion
use your legs brah
okay agree at your head and use your
legs man if you move your feet your
brain will follow bro tighten up you
don't care what kind of hat you have on
dude Stephen Hawkins was negative us
[ __ ] all the time like
world is gun and it's like all right
dude yeah yeah one button I think it
said game over on it yeah people asking
about it everything was negative what's
your favorite pizza pizza kills stop
eating
we flew your ass all the way from
[ __ ] give us a speech just [ __ ] on
the world is dying all right man it
sounds like Sansa
you two really had a spring down yeah
but you live and learn I implore
learning man and I love that about you
do what else mean I'm not learning so
there we meet a boy Jaden from Perth
Australia
oh good day mate oh yeah how you don't
Brendon Jayden from Perth Australia got
a bit of a debate club here for ya I
want to know what you prefer to do jump
out of a plane skydiving or do bungee
jumping let us know what you think Gang
Gang but Chuck well sure guys Britain
sipping something brown to chug in that
but bro
black coffee if she's fine enough ah but
dude
Bunji disgusting Brenda just speaking of
my real truth bro Roberts like that the
Lord's work I didn't know that was your
truth do but Chuck can kill the thing is
is listen bungee jumping or [ __ ] jump
out of planes how about neither I want
to live bro I wanna live you know what
it feel like to have someone tell my kid
I died does jump out a [ __ ] plane
feel awesome bungee jumping you know
stupid that [ __ ] is cadiz and cons cat
and your culture a lot of parents die
they kill themselves out of honor
what is more honorable to have your
parent died from with no man's problem
you know I'm sorry I interrupted you man
let's go jump or jump out of a plane
but I like where you're going with this
deal why I'm sorry for interrupting you
though you're fine I was done you were
yeah you actually saved me now you
[ __ ] me now you know nobody will dwell
on something like me man I'm a dweller
what do you guys do yeah what happens if
if your father's gonna kill himself or
something because if something happened
at the company is it better that he died
skydiving or bungee jumping oh it's
gonna be skydiving because that's 100%
him taking responsibility
whereas bungee jumping is like taking
responsibility for what he did
yeah I'm a tire owner yeah that's a good
call my tire rope and just hope see what
happens dude you know cat join a
motorcycle gang I don't know if you
noticed that income honor for all really
is that real yeah it's real damn [ __ ]
snake it looks nice on that dope I
joined the triad she sent me that went
that [ __ ] she sent me that [ __ ] is sexy
though like well that's a sexual
harassment Brendan and what's the
couldn't read on send it you know oh she
sent you that picture yeah no way that
[ __ ] is sexy oh I felt bad I said risky
risky but I knew what you meant you know
I met in this culture if you like you
look dope with a neck tattoo cat you
know you look pretty sweet too just
right here bro yeah I could get that
yeah you could pull it off any order
right along my aorta a little here just
put a order here [ __ ] yeah with an arrow
yeah and then two little vampire things
like they're sucking on yeah
hashtag too but no I would put two
handprints where they could get my pulse
in case I was ever hurt or something
apply here yeah but cats on it okay it's
okay very much yeah if you're so a man
that it's not honorable died a bungee
jump no absolutely not
both suck if I'm gonna die I want to die
of something badass that would make CNN
if I jump out a plane I die bungee
jumping not making CNN if I jump into a
great white sharks mouth making seeing
it oh yeah that's what I'm going for
yes p.m. - yeah done Anna done shut RTS
p.m. which I did make a few weeks ago so
just [ __ ] did you that up yeah play it
right now guys top six baby plays of the
week right there
so just headed I don't get it play
number six my number six they have a guy
named HAMP that was playing and he the
he referenced HAMP because I used to
raise hamsters and stuff when I was
young not raised when they go so the the
players name was HAMP and the god castor
shout the Obama
oh that's dope no man sorry gang you've
been acting different that make sense
really yeah yeah
I still holding me around and [ __ ] time
to pay the bill
Mac Weldon or Mac Daddy boo oh I'll say
this I've been in Underpants I don't
even remember since I only remember
honestly I remember when I started
wearing them but when I do bra I feel
like a chant I feel like a champion
there's nothing I like better than
feeling my nuts and wiener a little bit
closer to my body and they should yeah
me too man thank God for Mac well the
Mac Daddy will be the most comfortable
underwear socks shirts under shirts
hoodies sweatpants that you will ever
put on your body
smoke your cousin's nuts brothers no
better way to do with them I getting
somebody a pair of Mac Weldon
undershorts yeah get your nuts bro dude
I'll take your stepdads nuts and toss
them into a fireplace bro if these
aren't the best underwear ever chestnuts
roasting on the open uncle five that's
bro get them right now and you guys can
get a special deal right now twist off
your first order when you visit Mac
welding dot-com enter promo code cat TTL
baby praise the Lord I'll burn down a
damn Dunkin Donuts preemie and if I do
it I'm doing that [ __ ] and a pair of M
dubs you feel me if Mac well thence I'm
telling you brought these things just
sturdier than a frickin thick girl
outside of a [ __ ] barbecue taco truck
dog these things are they got gristle on
him bro these are the type underwear you
need go to Mac Weldon come enter promo
code tats that's it for your 20% off
your first order visit Mac Weldon calm
and enter promo code k 80s it's time get
those drawers knock knock who's there
hey Theo Brendan bro I'm sick of all
these guys tucking in the shirt looking
like a bunch of doors oh dude I have a
friend from Kentucky I said you should
be from untuck E yeah dude and the
holidays are here may know what that
means
untuck your stuff with on-target shirts
that are designed to be on top but I've
ever been untuck E I have not oh it's
great man nobody has their shirt tucked
in it and and everybody looks great dude
you ever seen a guy rockin on untucked
button-down shirt it looks bad you're
like what are you doing oh yeah what are
you doing is there like a curtain or
something with little buttons on the
front they make sense it's confusing
yeah it's like are you in a wedding or
something what are you even doing dude
yeah but here's the thing where do you
go to find out on tuckable shirt that
looks good you go to on tuck it on tuck
it that's you ntuc Kay IT comm promo
code katstra 20% off the best on Tucket
shirt you've ever done yeah Wow someone
always I almost had to untuck your
tongue bro you want to chuck my Brady
dude I don't know if we're get ever
gonna be able to do that but I do know
that the best place to get that shirt
that's gonna look comfortably you know a
little bit of espanol you know Papa Doc
yeah okay untuck it calm UNT you see
okay i T comm promo code cats for 20%
off get that comfortable top piece man
look nice don't tuck it in brother st.
this ain't uh this ain't Church man oh
yeah Bill Gates untuck it feel good this
is gonna get even go to church who knows
untuck it dot-com from a code cats for
20% off someone's got to pay for
Brennan's coffee habit
I'd say neither I'm not into skydiving
or a bungee God say neither shulman dude
I [ __ ] say neither Schulman on that
one bro I say toe wait no [ __ ] that
brought wasn't thinking about it you'd
have Stephen Hawkins try one of there oh
my god I'm so scared
game over you're out of your mind
pendant or to be awesome for him this is
what it sounds like a fly he changed the
word at the end of that a world is a
vampire
do deserve lbrahim when Stephen Hopkins
turned in a [ __ ] check in that movie
have you seen that movie dude all this
Danish girl ah dude the Danish girl when
Steven Hopkins turns into a [ __ ]
chick yeah I haven't seen it but I can
imagine
I bet it's easier to be a chick when
you're in a wheelchair just people want
to see you walk or move around and
that's a cable while you yeah
they don't know what your cheeks look
like yeah it's just more of a giveaway
when you have to move around or show how
your body moves because a male body
moves differently mm-hmm till you they
that we don't know right it's easier as
a as someone that has the conviction of
a wheelchair the or someone that's in a
wheelchair wheelchair is gonna hide them
curves yeah you hide your cheeks I had
no idea this is a while I had no idea
you had them two hamsters hanging out
the back dude shoutout ham Sisson bro I
had no idea shoutout Furman University
all right dude dude skydiving I don't
know shout-out Perth brah beautiful
place oi oi hey Rocky Higgy walkie would
you go in for just a it's got over
budget
skydiving's G [ __ ] man it's got I've got
his G [ __ ] bro tying yourself to a
cording jumping off of something bro
anybody could do that in her [ __ ]
yard yeah what are you nine there's
people doing that you know I remember
they had to do buzz he tied a rope to
his feet and jumped off on the side of
his [ __ ] house dude and [ __ ] broke
I think like two or six of his ribs he
broke one eleventh of his ribs so
whatever that is
it's called jackass you've seen how
that's showing no this was bungee jump
this was early bungee jumping dude for
they you know a lot of the measurements
were going around just thing with bungee
on them can move on when people bungee
jump in Mexico
you're gonna trust homeboy with the Rope
every goddamn day you paying them 50
[ __ ] pesos you gonna trust that guy
to tie your head correctly I got your
goddamn mind we're in Florida yeah
that's a great point Brenda name all the
place you can bungee jump I trust and
[ __ ] I'm Miguel with my life for
twenty pesos you don't say yeah
any place you can bungee jump for less
than seven dollars just [ __ ] kill
yourself and given somebody $6.99 any
blame on poor Miguel he shut his
operation down ah dude bro here's a
place bro and also Florida as a place
for villa to bungee jump
everywhere you go let's go Florida you
get a Shoney's in Florida no less you
[ __ ] bunch it up for 30 bucks outside
Florida or basically as I like to call
it often north Mexico okay let's be
realistic man we got to shut it down
guys safety first I'm gonna say
skydiving it's a little bit more
regulated you get a lot of post military
OHS that work in that industry because
you know they love the experience of
being up in these jets and jumping I'm
gonna go skydiving all day it's an
actual real experience look at bungee
jumping just cuz way more dangerous mmm
84% limit skydiving 84% of great people
yeah but I want to know this man let's
get let's get a vote who's more likely
what was the thing they wanted it with a
few minutes ago we couldn't decide what
it was who's more likely to die doing
something are we talking about that we
weren't are you saying between you and
me yeah I sure know who's more luck what
was it it was who's gonna kill
themselves fast Oh who's going to hell
yeah oh so say it's a tough call we'll
put that up on a nicer you're definitely
going out all the time dude you
I hope I pray dude I've been in a church
oh wow
bro no dude you think you think Church
you think churches are a lie I was born
in the church Oh enough with the bryan
callen impersonation Tim Tebow is a
buddy of mine he texts Jesus what's up
now bro he's never been a guest on TFA
TK bro so he's not that close
I'll say this do Carl Lentz is a buddy
of mine bro
never heard of him Carl Lentz you know
him Master bro no not Carl Weathers
where that guy died this is alive bro
Carl Weathers is the Lyceum in Venice
all the time thriving no he doesn't he
rode that horse and I need to do this
commercial is about senior citizen
safety break Oh Carl Weathers is driving
he's Jack the things on trt dude who
does it's a white guy on horse doing
commercials for old people can you
google whether it's black also known as
Apollo you think there's only one Carl
Weathers dude there's only one that
matters okay I'll tell you this 80 out
of probably 92 Carl Weathers is white
white I'll give you that okay that's why
you got famous bro oh you think you're
thinking of the yeah what is it say what
do we get if we do wise like on horse
doing commercials for old people old
white guy get up at all I know who's
your [ __ ] guns close dude I'm gonna
tell you Oh Carl Lentz bro bring up Carl
Lentz KRC ah she's a very good question
you know it's not is he white see but
when it comes to letters you ask me Carl
Lentz man oh the American pillow song
chairs gang [ __ ] bro that's Jesus at a
birthday Jesus [ __ ] boy what is he
wearing hot you're a [ __ ] the Lord's
[ __ ] boy look at the way he's dressed
and I celebrate it I celebrate it
I don't want my pastor in [ __ ] in
[ __ ] God fear of God clothing you
know I'm saying I don't want my
pastoring ye
because he loves Yeezy Christ bro that's
why dude what do you mean bro you want
your pack dude look look at him
oh that's bets [ __ ] Kanye's
collection season 6 bro that's not the
Lord's work probably he's doing it to
you and I we do his [ __ ] bro do you
think he's close to having us
oh I think he'd have to dig you out of
hell but I think we're both close to
heaven oh he is if there's a stoop
he's definitely where he's on the stoop
work but we're [ __ ] maybe on the
second stair bro but I want to know who
is more likely to go to hell I want our
fans to vote or me
the listeners to vote can we put that up
who's most likely to I think who's most
likely to die before 80 is also fair
well let's do this one first is that
okay sure
let's do one first just hear me out on
dying before 80 huh I'm gonna die before
you cuz if just picture this all dogs go
to heaven but big dogs don't last long
I'm like a Great Dane you're like a
border collie okay this sounds like
something out of a [ __ ] on the line
that got cut out of babe pig in the city
okay so I don't know what you're talking
about okay big guys don't name the
biggest grandpa you know oh no big guys
don't live long okay so big guys he'll
be guys and I see each other down there
dude I can't believe the [ __ ] you're
taking Tebow over Lintz bro dude Tebow
can [ __ ] tax with Jesus Christ this
guy is in [ __ ] Yeezy 711
okay no pastor I know now I'm a Bieber
fan I'm a Bieber fan Bieber's in that
picture - dude JB's a [ __ ] legend but
I'm saying that this guy Karl Lance is a
good man dude he's a good man shirt off
I'll give them this bodies from heaven
from that oh you don't think the rest of
them could I'm just sayin bloody they're
trying to keep the shorts off why you
said that Pope now you're getting closer
to heaven man
shut up the Tebow in Carl Lentz man I'm
just kidding Carl yeah and I'm just
kidding ah give me a sexy preacher you
can wear some dope clothes
I'm a fan your body bro yeah it's about
a spirits not about his ease in Jordan
threes that he's in that are $700 flying
private jets you can't jump though you
gotta have a little bit you got to have
some decent boots you need some decent
boots some very rare Jordan threes to
get the heaven we all do only the Lord
could jump in sandals but only JC could
jump in sandals dawg yeah he's the last
one ever do it mm-hmm he's the last one
to ever do it are you going to having
cat let's get cat in here dude am I
going to heaven yeah all cats go to
heaven well I was raised Buddhist so I
think I would be reincarnated that's
what I'm saying a shout out all
reincarnated as I don't know hopefully I
mean obviously like you're Moody as a
real cat though you know I'm saying you
you got a very cat vibe the feline yeah
it's not obvious what you're gonna be
raining hard Oh black cat right huh just
a CAD you you don't seem you don't need
to see color when you talk about animals
Brendan you free I don't see her as a
tabby cat you know I'm saying oh maybe a
Pokemon oh yeah I could see once you
guys masturbating in the park what are
you doing uh
with your wiener oh yeah I don't know
what happened some guys scored 40 on me
a middle-school life just gone downhill
since it's pretty traumatic you know I
didn't choose this life yeah you know
Jason Williams have you heard of him no
no not that one Orange Julius that's out
of shape now but get a mean jumper for a
while there Roy Hills all right what
else we got what was this guy's issue
again you guys answered it was bungee
jumping what was through this episode
we've only got two categories but the
next thing is on topic with what y'all
been talking about which is crazy I
don't know it's some relation do it you
know who did man he did tl baby hear
this question you saw no way to you this
question what if you do a 70 times
you'll turn [ __ ] pink bro you're
right brah it goes a long distance he's
got thrown full racks of ribs at I got
fat all right what do you got this is
our boy Jacob Conner asking for a
relationship advice and ironically let
me say this for even start his initials
are JC come on what is happening right
now wait for you what is happened dude
don't ask but the dough feelin I know go
through your body we'll see what they
say but and that is we're gonna put it
up on the thing and that can be a new
category that will start to who's more
likely you know heaven hell or there
needs to be a category like heaven hell
we ought to pick someone if they're
going to heaven hell or what's the third
category Heaven Hell or Sea World
you know I'm saying boy we can only put
you on the Instagram right yeah only to
want Instagram on Twitter we can put up
to I think five or six well it's already
gotten complicated let's you can do
other people do yeah who's more likely
to go to hell that's what we'll do for
this first one and then after that we'll
take some suggestions where if you want
to ask who's so you can vote on
Instagram who's more likely to go to
hell
cavil
set up on Instagram for us and then
after that you can send in for a year
for a new segment who's more likely more
likely to join Isis yeah yeah great
question that's perfect dude yeah who's
more likely to get indoctrinated in
nicest this weekend in Dallas
are you one of their co-workers boys an
Isis member this guy all right we got JJ
won't bro shouts a JJ whoa who gets hurt
every year I'm sending this in to get a
little relationship advice I've been
dating my girl for about four months now
amen and her parents don't want us to
date because apparently I'm not a
devoted Christian ah so I'm wondering
what you guys think I should do keep
sneaking around with her like we have
been the last couple months or just
break things off before we get too much
further let me know Gang Gang butt plug
oh he's into the dark arts I wouldn't
let my daughter hang out that guy either
what's the Christian comic uh John
Christ dude do what John Christ it just
fake the funk bro and blast not dude
just just buy [ __ ] Kanye's new Yeezy
season seven like his friend and pretend
you're religious dude
and then you marry girl and she knows
what's up she's obviously cool you don't
know what [ __ ] John palm 17 is or
whatever it's Psalms first of all okay
dude Paul's a porn star that's how I
know okay dude buy some [ __ ] Stone
Cold Steve Austin shirts with the
[ __ ] 3:16 on it but never no dude
just funk you can hear the votes adding
up for who's going to hell can't you
can't you just hear the votes adding up
your spirit is in the drain brother have
you have you did you grow up going to
church yeah not a time but I went some
time my dad favorite verse huh god is
great God is good God we thank you for
this food that's over here bro eyes
hands we all
faith like you love for daily bread
you gotta tighten up dog are you gonna
[ __ ] you know where you gonna end up
I wanna be there bro love you way to hug
me Nelly bro it's gonna be dude it's
gonna be you boy
they gonna be noodle in a bunch of old
men noodle in you I'm saying bro you
gotta tighten up this guy this is a good
question man this is a real good
question
you're young dude if you love or fake
the funk you don't know them [ __ ] dude
well yeah it's true it's opting also if
the real Christians they shouldn't be
judging you either for the probably them
fake-ass Christians okay I know I'm
digging myself deeper to hell you should
forgive Pammy or shovel man pull my
shovel um I don't know man this is it
here's the thing if her parents if
that's what they want it's like it I
could imagine if I'm a parent and the
kid is like but you seem like a nice kid
this guy seems like a nice cool yeah
yeah he's got braces dude that's brave
as [ __ ] to wear braces metal ones yeah
19 year but you Bay do you [ __ ]
you're basically the Flavor Flav of our
generation dude if you [ __ ] wearing
that it's crazy that's brave as [ __ ]
dude you're like basically the Forrest
Gump of [ __ ] grills you a young
carrot top so same right that's a mean
[ __ ] do either bobby schmurder of your
generation if you wear [ __ ] metal
braces like a white Takashi six minutes
bro well every other [ __ ] is is doing
these you know there's a line mail or
something somebody
dude a buddy of mine got the wrong one
sent oh dude he looks like a senior
citizen yeah ro it's insane all it takes
is one [ __ ] Amazon mix-up cuz your
[ __ ] delivery dudes too high and next
thing you know you got the teeth of a
[ __ ] newborn [ __ ] kitten you know
she's kidding you know you have the
teeth of a crocodile it takes you a
minute and a half to smile because you
got 2,000 [ __ ] teeth bruh so that's
what I'm saying dude mad respect to you
for stick keeping it old school and keep
it that's like heaven the Jordan ones on
your [ __ ] smile I like this kid man
look it's obvious you care about the
girl cuz you're even caring about this
question man I think you could present
to the to the parents look you know I
don't know how I feel you know like I'm
doing the best that I can I do not care
about your daughter and then let them
deal with that at that at that point
because if that's you if that's your
truth if you're just trying to [ __ ] man
and that's a different story but I would
just I don't know man I don't even know
Brendon Oh Christian catfish this [ __ ]
yeah
what is out you're young dude kind of
read up a little bit by the Bible for
dummies read up a little bit let the
pinch you know know what's up you're not
gonna marry the bra dude you're sixteen
with braces no of your life bro you
ain't going to hell I challenge you to
marry her dude I don't don't do that
Bernie's a [ __ ] bro no I'm not uh-huh
put you in one healthy relationship
listen your boy head listen to your boy
okay keep the braces you got me with
that one if you can do braces these days
metal braces you could do a marriage
bruh give me new braces you do anything
oh it's like putting braces on your
wiener brah
you know you could do a marriage easy
dude and plus if you have a couple of
kids button a church family there's
nothing they love more when you throw a
few kids in her child yeah they love
that [ __ ] what do you think about this
Derek you regnant yeah Derek I know this
is probably your I'm a big man pretend
to be Christian bro everybody else is
doing it well we're never gonna be all
of us are fuck-ups man you know what I'm
saying we just try our best forgive
I know I shall forgive I'm trying to
forget thou shalt not kill
alright thou shalt forgive thy shall
bust not in line of the true word of
Jesus Christ Rowley that's a [ __ ]
dart game man it's a dart game out there
religion to the darkest game religion is
a dark game man we think my world
religions done over all the day about
people fighting for religion there's
more people than anything else people
believe in their faith though man people
believe in it yeah you know it's wild
whatever get you through the day bro
well here's the thing man I believe in
faith but I don't believe I'm not gonna
take a sword to somebody if they don't
believe what I believe that's crazy
especially when I'm still figuring out
what I believe you know mm-hmm we'll
fight and sword and I don't I need some
evidence bro
you got a look in your heart for that
man yeah I guess science bro there's a
little box of my lambo for it that's me
Khorasan it's on wheels what do you
think about this kid what do y'all think
about this kid let's go to the culture
corner man we don't know [ __ ] Brendon I
like him Andy he's a cutie he's a
youngster you know what I mean ho ho
he's like 40 Oh pastor Poston what would
you do cat
I mean he's 16 white why is he talking
to her parents I've never talked to any
of the parents of the guys I've dated in
high school
really interesting that's very
interesting
why not I definitely had to deal with
some parents I wasn't allowed to have a
boyfriend growing up I wasn't allowed to
have friends and 12 like in college my
mom did not want me to have well then
this is perfect in for you so what so
what we imagine if this was your
boyfriend in high school or something
and this is the question he sends in you
know I like cat let's go let's play it
back and we'll put cat in there
what's up Theo what's up Brandi
I'm sending this in to get a little
relationship advice I wonder who he's
seeing I've been eating my girl for
about four months okay pause it
and her parents his girl whoo
cat hmm he's dating cat for months
Wow for four months this guy really
cares about her it seems like her it
looks like he's in a church when he's
sent in this yeah it does confession
booth the thing is is four months in his
little lifetime that's forever
yeah they got rings and [ __ ] it's like
5% of his life yep 16 if I was dating a
guy for four months I wouldn't bring him
to anything I'd only hang out with him
in private Kat is a savage hey Siri
what's 16 times 12 so four months of 192
that's basically it's like 2% of his
life he spent with with cats a lot of
time cat that's not enough time for me I
would not have had brought him to my
parents okay but this is how he's
feeling so you don't even give a [ __ ]
about him so let's imagine that now so
the guy cares you don't care let's keep
playing I don't want us to date because
apparently I'm not a devoted Christian
what's that he's doing these days
wondering what you guys think I should
do keep sneaking around with her like we
have been for the past couple months or
just break things off before we get too
much further let me know Gang Gang butt
plug that's why I can't get you in the
house brother the butt plug beam ain't
gonna get you in the Lord's house Derek
flared up when he heard it no no no
either pastor P to make him say God if
this was me I feel like I would have
told my parents there's this guy who has
a crush on me I don't want to spend any
more time with him can you please make
up an excuse for why we can't see each
other cuz he's not taking a hit oh wow
if that was me yeah cuz that's the
problem we don't get here is we don't
get what the I know yeah we need the
other girl I wish we'd get both sides I
need more facts well here's what we can
do we can ask him said hey you know
December 14 I need all information
that's about
requested not to pick some a
fourteen-year-old girl makes it worth
your time not do I said too much
euphoria bro from are you sure I don't
think we have insurance dude - do not
send pics do not send pics of children
us man wait on the holiday you might be
21 no he said I what he is did me you
didn't know you didn't know that's never
mind then again I need more info stem
pics sim pics of anyone that's over 18
man yeah but here's the thing bro
I think if we could get her take on this
I think we'd be able to maybe give a
better suggest you never get the woman's
take do it but that's the problem
sometimes with Sookie wasting yeah it's
like with people looking for advice or
suggestions they can't well here's the
problem or crowds real [ __ ] fest I don't
think it is we get a lot of females do
we I think so
well for a flop my on know they send
only promises all the girls are sending
stuff they just they just send in like a
what up do well you must be using a for
something cuz I've never seen one of
those pictures let me tell you some if
you get one of those if you get a few of
those run it by us I don't need a man
I'm trying to keep I'm trying to I've
enough problem dude I see something I'll
think about man qinger staying at my
[ __ ] on my butthole and I'm like whoa
lady we use it all right well good luck
to this guy man do the Lord's work in
life wow man I'm gonna say look man I
think you know I think if you really
care about it presented to her folks and
say look this is how I feel about your
daughter
you know if I'm not religious enough for
you or something this or play he'll tell
me you believe in voodoo see how it goes
dude no I like that too bro
if you want me boss and your [ __ ]
drew brees Jersey dog and telling them
you know put so dad put some [ __ ]
dead squirrel skeletons around your neck
tell me believe in the dark arts Brodie
I knew a guy who used to sell aah aah
raccoon penis necklaces dude I'd buy one
swear to god this dude outside of Iowa
oh yeah I found one so and outside of
why I'll buy ya outside of Iowa but what
else would I do good luck
go wrap it up those particular stinger
boys yeah that Danis thing they charge
this thing stop hitting it please first
stop hitting it dude Courtney from
Cleveland Ohio
this is our girl Courtney she's a welder
hey Theo and Brendan I'm Courtney King
adore sing it for you women doing
blue-collar jobs Gang Gang buzz-buzz did
she weld after at the end or no she
didn't do anything after but that was it
that was it is she breaking into a bank
vault what are we doing here because she
wants to it's good I like this I like
this lady I like that hard-working lady
right there she's out there well done
dude get your hands dirty girl oh dude
she definitely uh she's [ __ ] John
well Bobbitt bro she could [ __ ] weld
your Weiner right off if you don't
behave I respect it I respect it not
gonna buy the product I respect it just
kidding you wouldn't I'm you did a
female like a weld yeah we be cool she'd
weld cool [ __ ] for me mm-hmm
well some more of these yeah bottle
opener Steve make us like a metal chair
something a friend hair be nice
the weldings kind of going out of
business yeah yeah
19:15 so our weldings kind of going on
business yeah going out of business
burnin what do you think keeps walls up
what do you think keeps bridges up show
me a bridge in another country right now
that has fell down Google bridge falls
oh really
kills many Google that and not amen am I
in and ie not that I know her but that's
I'm not talking about her bridge
recently a bridge fell Brendon yeah look
at this one that's Florida is it a
college bro goddamn that's one of the
new-age bridges what do you mean new-age
bridges dude it's a bridge God dang
there you go look at that [ __ ] guess you
probably put this grocery guy vehicles
five vehicles first of all that bridge
looks they don't even [ __ ] need it
bro dude get a damn crosswalk dawg
sister they wanted so students can cross
over and sit across from the busy street
and
I'm crossed right into the Lord's arms
bro fi you bro you gotta say this a man
for dead [ __ ] when you when you win fi
you when two of the letters are fu tying
going there brah I don't believe in it
either fu bruh f su yeah they're
struggling oh they are a man they got
Ryan leach I think over there at
quarterback that's not good dude Ryan
yeah I'm down with girls doing this [ __ ]
man it's kind of cool is she the cutest
hell yeah yeah Derek I'll throw it in
your microwave oven over there with a
heat burner right afterwards you can
throw that ball did any welder head off
well get to wear cool hats you got a
free Halloween costume right when you
leave work if you want we have their
school gloves yeah you get the best
thing is watching somebody who's winning
a welder helmet go order at a drive-thru
and not lift their [ __ ] thing up
god that's gangster Oh take me to heaven
with that bra that shit's sexy shout out
to this girl you know your boys King
here [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of it last one
this is a star boys zeal King in this
team zeal done doing some dirt I mean
work at that big double D dirty double D
write them up bro white people with
dreads you feel me yes oh no bus Keith
key dang I like this guy I am very
unique man ziyal is his name you like
ultra appropriation here Duncan dönitz
David over there dude let's play one of
my favorite videos of all time if you'll
go to the Duncan Don it's burns down
Dunkin Donuts burn down oh this is the
best video that's ever happened
Julie a lot of people in Shamokin are
upset that Dunkin Donuts is closed
because they didn't have anywhere else
to go for coffee and doughnuts today we
also learn information about the teenage
girl police charged with setting the
place on fire yellow tape surrounds the
Dunkin Donuts on West Sunbury Street and
Shamokin samogon it's closed until
further notice there's a lot of people
that's definitely gun
a teenager is charged with starting a
fire inside the restaurant on Saturday
night Restaurant damage police officer
ray psycho says no damage psycho says
the fire the toilet paper dispenser was
lit on fire and within about a minute
the entire place was filled up with
smoke the mother did explain that she's
recently been put on new medication
officer race who admitted to setting the
fire is currently at a juvenile
detention center now I have to rely on
myself to go to maybe a turkey hill or
something where I don't like there tonot
side rather the donuts at Dunkin Donuts
and I'm kind of dealing with it but I
really miss Dunkin Donuts um coffee
power rate if I'm dehydrated I sit there
all the time if I have any like legal
work that I need to do I go there I meet
with my attorneys there damn model my
friends go in there get the cold coffee
well iced coffee I guess it's called
people miss their what they call frozen
water call it's a location where you can
meet up with your friends it's the only
thing this town has gang [ __ ] but [ __ ]
was hilarious shoutouts Shamokin bruh
shut up
swag it shut up to everybody that
survives out there and Dunkin Donuts
when they try to burn them down - [ __ ]
dude shut up this dude rocking the
dreads kind of similar with that 16 year
old with braces it really takes some
courage to do that and up the Milan
problem they smell like [ __ ] bro hmm not
if you smell like hummus not if you
thread a little bit of potpourri up in
there somewhere put a cinnamon stick in
each one especially with the holidays
lumen dude you could throw a pumpkin
spice backsplash on those [ __ ] ropes
bro
you know Sam make your whole [ __ ]
world smell like a damn Starbucks dawg
you'll be [ __ ] in an instant tell ya
I'm gonna price ting the white dreads I
just sting them if you want dude yeah I
believe anybody could do to dredge if
they really want to do them it takes a
brave person to do them I take some time
to you put wax in it and [ __ ] and we
don't see a lot of Asian dreads why is
that okay hmm
you know I've never noticed that until
this point there are a lot of dreads has
ever been an Asian with dreads huh maybe
Jackie Chan in that one movie like uh
Forbidden Kingdom or something yeah
dreads and that is probably a wig yeah I
don't think people get away make dreads
oh that's why it just doesn't live does
it oh there's a company well Julian have
dreads
Linsanity dude dude and he was a
national champion with the Toronto
Raptors people won't forget I mean he
played as many minutes as you and I but
yeah but he played him dude at least
some [ __ ] janitor didn't score 40 on
him and his [ __ ] chubby buddy I think
they did in China now for one chicken so
huh that looks like chin a little bit
if chin was more gangster no I thought a
little racist their chin definitely
starts to resemble a lot of other Asian
men I've met I will admit that part but
I think he doesn't my choice he tries
not to stand out
I wish Chen would grow dreads but he
can't he could if he wanted and I
struggle with the shave head he could if
he wants to now the Lord's getting us
here again oh it could be man may may
the Lord as I'm one at bra the Lord
don't put a crop on everybody man's sake
Lord sometimes I'm for some people Lord
your barber yeah that's there no choice
that barbershop seventh heavens
barbershop is open all the time
some people 24/7 uh good luck out there
man at the Dunkin Donuts I see the fall
leaves in the background man it's a
seasonal time it's a beautiful time of
year guys yeah good for you man with the
dreads
yeah we got a sale coming up under on
merchandise for
stuff that Black Friday shoutout Derrick
and you could get that deal man that's
Derek's deals we're gonna have a whole
little section on air called Derrick's
dealers tearing steel so that's it now
we're gonna put that on there dairies
deal corner you on the road anytime soon
brother what am i doing man I got a show
coming up December 10th at The Wiltern I
got tickets going on sale for Red Bank
New Jersey the show in Salyersville got
moved to red bank and Oxon Hill Maryland
that show is back on it's gonna be in
February nice brother um otherwise yet
that's pretty much about it right now I
mean there's other shows coming up but
they're they're gonna announce them yeah
they're at Lafayette December 26 there
already are they're all in website Theo
van calm slash tour
I'm in Dallas this weekend Thursday
Friday Saturday and the next weekend
I'm at wise guys in Utah and then just
went on sale La Jolla Comedy Store
December get your tickets
oh nice what desi down there 1718 Wow
right before the holidays yeah this
beautiful man you're in town for
Christmas
I'm sorry Thanksgiving no I think I'm
gonna enter Louisiana and chill out I
want to go see a Saints game it'll be
dope and uh well I'm gonna figure it out
yes sir
Oh getting buzzed gang gang buzz buzz
mansion right now so shut up Carla shut
up Tim Tebow shut up Carl Weathers shut
up Jesus shadow JC man shout-out to JC
walkers yeah thank you very much Kat
thank you very much Derek we out
[Music]
the king
[Music]